14 years after you fell in love with The Incredibles,
your favorite super family returns with an all-new adventure
featuring surprise twists that will keep you guessing.
Unless you remember anything at all about the first movie.
"You can't count on anyone, especially your heroes."
"Superheroes keep us weak!"
Eh, it's a safe bet, actually.
Pixar's target demo was Jack-Jack's age back then.
Experience fan-favorite director Brad Bird's sixth feature film
and his fourth about how regular schmucks like us need to suck it up and let the gifted play by their own rules.
In a Pixar film that continues their tradition of passable sequels that don't hit the mark of the first one,
except that one time when it was even better
and that one time when it was so, so much worse.
"Agent? You mean like insurance agent? Like..."
♫ Like a good neighbor, Mater is- ♫
NO!
Suit up once more with the Incredibles.
Bob is a dad who just wants to turn his children into living weapons
while Helen just wants a cool action setpiece of her own for once.
Last time, they learned to trust each other and fight crime as a family unit
after a mishap where one of the parents did illegal hero work on behalf of a techno genius who turned out to be a villain
and the public learned to love superheroes again.
Now, after 15 minutes of erasing all that progress,
"So now, we've gotta go back to never using our powers."
watch the Parrs learn to trust each other again
and fight crime as a family unit...
again.
After a mishap where one of the parents does illegal hero work again on behalf of a techno-genius again
who turns out to be a villain...again.
And the public learns to love superheroes again again.
And if you think they're gonna mess with this formula for the next one,
I can give you 1.2 billion reasons why they won't.
Looking to spoil the fun is the evil Screenslaver,
a villain who uses screens to hurt people,
including the audience.
She believes heroes are a dangerous menace we shouldn't rely on,
which the movie never really disputes,
"That's a rocket launcher!"
"Sweet!"
and has some incredibly solid points about the harm of society's nonstop consumption of media,
"Break a sweat, participate in life."
which of course makes her the villain in a Disney movie!
Shut up, evil lady that wants us to go outside!
Real heroes are already subscribed to Disney's streaming service!
Woohoo! Look at all that IP!
Aw, yeah. Get me all up in all that IP, man! I wanna bathe in it.
So enjoy a film with the exact same dynamic as the first time around,
that's still incredibly charming,
and holy moly, does it look good.
But after 20 films,
if another Pixar movie has a chase scene for a climax,
I'm gonna Dash myself off a cliff.
"We're almost there!"
"I'm gonna be sick, I'm gonna be sick."
Stop chasing!
There's other ways to end a film, you know!
Why don't you switch things up with a huge, world-ending threat that, like, menaces people by projecting some kind of, like, sky beam or something?
Wait.
What am I saying?
I've become what I hate the most!
Never mind!
Chase away to infinity and beyond!
Catherine Keener just really wanted to play another hypnotist?
Run, Frozone, run!
"You...have...POWERS!"
"Jack-Jack has powers?!"
Yeah, Incredibles, everyone knows Jack-Jack has powers. We found out in the last movie.
And Rick Dicker found out from the babysitter in Jack-Jack Attack.
Kinda surprised he didn't clue you in on all of this.
That's a real Rick Dicker move.
Heh heh, Rick Dicker.
That's a funny name.